but as i mentioned
if you want to lay the blame for the
failures in afghanistan at anybody's
feet
it has to be at the feet of george w
bush
and right now
both biden and twice impeached former
president donald trump
seem to want to lay the blame at each
other's feet
you've got members of the biden
administration coming out and saying no
everything that's happening right now is
donald trump's fault
and then trump of course is issuing his
idiotic statement saying look at all
these failures of biden i left him a
road map and he didn't follow it this is
his fault
these two going back and forth and back
and forth completely ignoring
that this all started under george w
bush folks and i know i've said this
plenty of times i've already said it
today it's gone through four
administrations at this point
but
george w bush's name was not mentioned
once
on the sunday talk shows this past
weekend not once
you cannot talk about afghanistan
without talking about george w bush and
the failures of the war on terror the
failures of this uh nation building that
we went on over there
that's where all the failures began
and yes it is accurate to say that both
democrat and republican administrations
came along after that and continued this
disastrous policy
but they weren't the ones who
implemented it everyone who has
inherited this afghanistan mess since
george w bush left office hasn't had a
road map they haven't known what the
heck to do over there
so we keep momming we keep sending
weapons
we keep the killing going we keep the
troops over there maybe we're going to
bring him home and maybe we're not
you know that happened during obama
and then instead oh no we're going to
send more
happened under trump we're going to
bring him home no wait we got it we got
to we got to send a few more we're going
to put more military contractors over
there we're going to bring troops back
some of them but we're going to double
down on the number of military
contractors we have over there that also
happened by the way earlier this year
with the biden administration because
nobody has known
what to do
because there was never any real goal
the so-called war on terror was such a
vague concept
that it could mean anything
and we went into it obviously with a lot
of hostility following 911
we were not thinking clearly as a nation
we wanted revenge we wanted retribution
and of course because
george w bush had all these you know
former officials from the first gulf war
in his administration they wanted to go
back over there and finish the job
so they focused on iraq they kept
afghanistan over there on the back
burner we got to do taliban yeah yeah
we're going to get them but iraq was the
big prize
so afghanistan fell by the wayside we
still kept troops there we still kept
fighting there
but never really had a plan there that
was kind of just the force show part oh
we're looking for bin laden over in
afghanistan that's that's what we're
doing over there but hey we just got
saddam hussein right and that's that's
what everybody wanted
following 911 as corey robin pointed out
on twitter the other day
90 of the american public supported
uh sending troops to afghanistan
so when i say we weren't thinking
clearly as a nation that's the kind of
thing i'm talking about here ninety
percent of people supported this thing
not knowing what it was really about not
knowing what was going on but george
bush and his administration lied us over
there
and got us stuck
and then they left and obama continued
then he left
and trump continued now we've got biden
pulling troops out
trump saying oh look at what an idiot
you are again ignoring the fact that
just a few months ago he was begging
biden to finish what he started pulling
all the troops out
at this point
it wouldn't have mattered if we had
pulled troops out of there in 2004 or
2010 or 2020 or even 2030
this would have happened
this same thing that we're watching
unfold right now with the taliban
capturing kabul this still would have
happened
because there was no goal
there was no strategy
there was no actual peace deal
negotiated between the u.s government
and the taliban and the afghani
government
and this is what we got
this is the disaster
that we have to deal with now
and again i don't think anybody really
knows what to do about this
do we just let the taliban take over
walk away and say well good luck you got
a mess on your hands
i i don't agree with sending troops back
over there i think it's just another
disaster you're just prolonging this
from happening again
and nobody knows the answer
the answer though is that we have to
continue to help the people of
afghanistan
we need to be able to get them out of
the country we need to take in as many
refugees as we possibly can here in the
united states i don't want to hear anger
from conservatives about this we put
them in this situation we've got to take
care of them
and that's the best thing we can do
right now
i am fair and cousins from ring of fire
more of me you can get it at ring of
fire or excuse me youtube.com slash the
ring of fire i'm sitting in for david
pakman today we'll be right back
one of our sponsors is magic spoon
breakfast cereal sweet and tasty like
the cereals i loved as a kid but without
the sugar or the carbs every serving of
magic spoon has zero grams of sugar only
four net carbs 140 calories and packed
with 13 grams of protein perfect if
you're doing keto perfect if you're
doing low carb great if you're just
trying to reduce your excess sugar
intake and because it's packed with
protein it's great before or after a
workout magic spoon flavors include
cocoa fruity frosted peanut butter
blueberry and cinnamon they're bringing
back cookies and cream they're bringing
back maple waffle you can build your own
variety box and try them all magic spoon
is so confident in the product if you
don't love it as much as i do they will
refund your money no questions asked go
to magicspoon.com pacman the link is
underneath this video and you'll get
five dollars off when you use the promo
code pacman at checkout